la france peut-elle entrée en guerre la
france est en guerre elle est en guerre
puisqu'elle met en place des sanctions
contre la russie ce printemps c'est une
guerre économique c'est une guerre
économique que c'est déjà une forme de
guerre il ya également l'armée de l'otan
qui est en cours de mobilisation avec
l'envoi de contagion donc on n'est pas
encore dans une danse nucléaire
militaire trick tos un sou mais on est
quand même dans une forme de guerre
juridique et économique et diplomatique
et des dommages moitié que raphaël alors
moi je peux vous parler d'économie
pourrais vous dire que la russie c'est
le premier exportateur de gaz pour
l'europe est le premier exportateur de
pétrole pour l'europe vous avez à peu
près 40% du gaz européen qui vient de
russie fait ça mais il ya une
interdépendance mutuel c'est à dire que
70% des recettes d'exportation de gaz
russe son pour l'europe donc il faut pas
surestimer n'ont plus la capacité de la
russie à faire un chantage à l'europe
par rapport au gaz alors vous pensez
qu'on en l'europe a quand même les
moyens de stopper assez vite le conflit
vous savez c'est comme en entreprise un
plus un salarié se sent faible plus
facilement il peut être licencié plus
vous êtes dans un rapport de force vous
savez quels atouts vous avez en main et
l'europe on a beaucoup plu vous pouvez
négocier les deux forces si vous
considérez que c'est eux qui ont les
cartes en main vous perdez alors il
l'europe a beaucoup de cartes en main
c'est le premier débouché de la russie
pour le gaz dans le monde beaucoup plus
que la chine n'a aujourd'hui est ce que
notre facture de gaz va augmenter dans
les prochains jours ou pas du tout alors
ça c'est une question différente c'est à
dire que y'a la france importe 99 % de
son gaz mais en termes de gaz russe ses
17 à 20% donc la france est l'un des
pays les moins exposées à la russie en
termes de gaz jma c'est clair sur ce
qu'il est donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que on dépend plutôt de la
norvège à 35 % pour le gaz consommé en
france à l'allemagne l'allemagne par
exemple et nous sommes plus dépendants
diplôme de leur rapport à ce qu'on dit
il ya des pays en europe qui dépendent à
55 60 70 % voire 80% du gaz russe la
france est l'une des moins exposés avec
17 à 20% donc pour les français qui nous
regardent ce soir la facture de gaza va
pas bouger dans les poches alors là il
ya deux manières de vous répondre syrie
la première c'est que le gouvernement
français a décidé un blocage des tarifs
du gaz jusqu'en juin 2022 d'accord donc
les tarifs que les français vont payer
11 millions de ménages seront les mêmes
que ceux du 1er octobre dernier d'accord
mais ça c'est parce qu'il ya un blocage
tarifaire après les élections les choses
peuvent changer et ça ça veut dire que
la répercussion du prix du gaz sur le
marché mondial peut être répercutée sur
la facture des ménages en france
d'accord la question aussi c'est la
hausse du prix du blé puisque l'ukraine
et la russie sont les principaux
exportateurs de blé qu'est ce qui va se
passer avec le blé par vous voulez qu'on
parle du blé des matières premières
agricoles avant le pétrole oui oui oui
après on parlera du pétrole 1 de la
série que le blé c'est vrai que c'est
effectivement l'ukraine on appelle
l'ukraine le grenier à blé de l'europe
et ses 12 % des exportations mondiales
de blé vienne d'ukraine donc quand vous
avez le cren qui est déstabilisé plus la
russie ça représente 25 % des
exportations mondiales de blé ça ça pose
un problème le blé a déjà pris 5% en
deux jours alors le blé voilà pour les
observer à quoi c'est à dire que la
bague à la baguette et blaye les patrons
est rebouché rabat ya déjà des
boulangers qui ont annoncé une hausse de
plusieurs centimes dans
l'es6 ainsi nasa ça arrive tout de suite
un shepard immédiat sur des prix élevés
puisqu'il y avait la relance écriture
qui avait boosté le prix des matières
premières donc ça ça c'est assad on va
le voir on va le sentir tout de suite
dès demain voilà heureusement sur le
pouvoir d'achat ça va se ressentir assez
rapidement vu sa csii appelé il ya ma
ici à l'huile de tournesol il ya un
instant du gaz donc on voulait redire un
mot sur le gaz 1 parce que le gaz nous
on est moins dépendante que l'allemagne
puisque on se fournit ailleurs mais
qu'est ce qui peut se passer lorsque je
voulais dire sur le cas c'est que il
faut diversifier les approvisionnements
c'est ça que le gaz il peut être sous
forme liquide avec d'autres fournisseurs
donc l'europe peut essayer de se
diversifier d'accord en achetant du gaz
dans d'autres pays et dépendre un peu
moins de de la russie c'est ça sur scène
donc il n'y aura pas de souci je voulais
qu'on parle maintenant de licence est-ce
qu'on va payer encore plus cher le plein
d'essence qu'il a réussi le deuxième
exportateur mondial de pétrole alors la
russie ses 10 à 12 % du pétrole mondial
oui premier exportateur de pétrole vers
l'europe et le pétrole ça représente
environ 30% du prix des carburants donc
quand vous avez une augmentation de 10
dollars sur le prix du baril le prix du
baril de pétrole aujourd'hui était à 104
dollars il a il a jamais été au dessus
de 100 dollars depuis sept ans vous
voyez on est vraiment un niveau très
élevé depuis sept ans mais il n'a pas
non plus atteint les 145 $ de la crise
financière de 2008 donc j'en vous dire
malheureusement si les choses
s'aggravent ça peut augmenter encore
plus et plus ça augmente plus à un
impact sur ses 30 points sans de prix du
pétrole qui détermine le prix du
carburant le reste en gros pour 60% ce
sont des taxes donc plus ça augmente
plus ça se ressent au bout de deux trois
semaines à la pompe pour les
automobilistes français c'est donc dans
deux ou trois semaines on peut peut-être
le ressentir bah je crains que ça va
peut-être cyril mais une certitude
exactement ça va ça va être quoi ça va
être une grosse augmentation ah bin là
ce serait vraiment je vais pas faire
comme les médecins qui pensaient que
dire sur le trop évident parce que j'ai
pas envie de me tromper mais en tout cas
c'est parti pour augmenter assez
fortement et atteindre 110 115 dollars
dans les prochaines semaines donc je
crains alors le gouvernement pourrait
baisser les taxes mais vous savez quand
on baisse d'un centime les taxes sur les
carburants le gouvernement la france
perd 500 millions d'euros ça doit vous
faire un bon arbitrage aussi andy gray
un centime ça se ressent peu sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages mais c'est
une grosse perte pour l'état et donc
l'état c'est un peu aussi s'est investi
pour nous les 500 millions d'années ce
que l'état va pas dire c'est
c'est les conséquences de la guerre on
peut pas faire autrement on voit que le
pouvoir d'achat des français entre le
bli on en parle il a un instant le bon
le gars ça devrait aller l'essence est
ce que ça va faire beaucoup non ça va
faire beaucoup et puis vous avez pas
mentionné parce que peut-être que vous
voulez pas le temps parle aujourd'hui
mais les tarifs de l'électricité aussi
bien sûr on aurait pas de bloquer mais
sans parler alors électricité va se
passer quoi c'est important électricité
c'est les prix ont fortement augmenté
c'est vrai que le prix de l'électricité
en france et dépendent à un marché
européen et saumade sur ce marché
européen c'est le prix du gaz qui fait
le prix de l'électricité c'est ça qui
est paradoxal c'est à dire qu'en france
on à 72% l'électricité qui est d'origine
nucléaire mais le prix de l'électricité
est déterminé par un marché européen
parce que la france fait partie d'un
marché une sorte de bourses européennes
et c'est ça que les français ne
comprennent pas à juste titre en lisant
attendez-vous nous dit on à 70 72 % de
nucléaire et là vous nous dites quand le
prix du gaz augmente le prix de notre
aide justement augmenter et donc on est
face à des à des budgets qui vont
exposer et plus vous êtes un ménage en
difficulté plus le prix du gaz du
carburant et de l'électricité et des
matières premières baguette pathé tout
pèse sur votre budget ces visas